just one look at the list of canceled
concerts and you can see
the impact the pandemic has had on the
live music
industry many artists soon turned to
streaming their performances
but one company has taken that idea a
step further
they're connecting bands with their fans
in a unique and intimate way
where music lovers can get a converted
front row seat a coveted rather we
should say
and sometimes a show all their own
anthony mason who else
has the story thank you we just got
married
when the pandemic struck in the spring
josie schuneman
and matt johnson had to reconsider their
wedding
you ended up having a much smaller
wedding than you planned
yeah yep yep basically we were i think
we invited around
250 people to the original reception and
just cut them all out yep we wound up
with like 18 people i think
they also had no band but still wanted
a wedding song you ready for your first
dance
yeah so on their may wedding day with a
cell phone
feeding sound through a bluetooth
speaker josie and matt
had their first dance
to joshua raiden's you got what i need
[Music]
the baby sang it himself
when i see you it's a
beautiful world so you had a personal
serenade
yes yeah it ended up being perfect
[Music]
that special moment cost the couple five
hundred dollars
and was arranged through a new company
called topeka
that was actually our hundredth one andy
levine is ceo
we can set you up to have a three song
serenade or an all request mini concert
or just have a conversation
did you do it did she say yes topeka has
also helped add the soundtrack
to wedding proposals good to see y'all
y'all look great
and has attracted top artists like jason
isbal
last night
same dream i have about twice a week
and singer-songwriter john hyatt
shrunken head
and mardi gras beads hanging on a
rear-view mirror
who performed his first topeka concerts
this summer were you surprised at all
at the demand for tickets i kind of was
to be honest with you yeah
were you yeah why i just didn't expect
900 people to go
hey i think let's let's go online and
watch hyatt sing some songs so it was
good not a headlight
but that's just how many fans paid for
tickets for two
concerts the top price 100
bought you a front row seat pairing zoom
and its own technology
[Music]
topeka can put up to 240 fans
right in front of the artists
hyatt came face to face with them when
he performed
with his daughter lily is it a different
experience to have like
zoom screens staring back at you well
you know initially i was a little
uh i thought oh this this may possibly
be even odder than just doing
a zoom show but but in fact uh after a
few songs
i started to get really comfortable with
it and feel like oh this is fantastic
there's the audience thank you so much
for sharing the evening with us
that connection levine says is what
topeka
is all about that's why we call it
topeka we're just real topeka people
you know from the movie almost famous
you're russell who still want it
in the 2000 cameron crow film singer
russell hammond
played by billy crudup is approached by
a van load of fans
i know you're a big rock star and all
but do you want to hang with some good
people looking to have a good time
or just real to peek at people man
for musicians forced off the road during
the pandemic
i like the way you're not afraid
topeka offers an intimate arena and
income we have a couple of artists that
are
doing a few hours a week and making
anywhere from
twenty five to forty thousand dollars a
month
and for fans like matt johnson and josie
schuneman
who salvaged their wedding dance thanks
to topeka
the moment was priceless
[Music]
what does that recording mean to you oh
it means so much i enjoy listening to
that song regularly but now that i can
go back and like listen to it
having joshua knowing he's saying it for
us is it means so much
you got my great ideas goosebumps right
yeah oh i know so i want my all-time
favorite bruce
barbara well i'm thinking of the wedding
song i'm like what would it have cost to
have michael
play on the first anniversary do home
another b
we will start working on both these
requests from you jeff
that's right i'll do it for you